c'è chi pure tesoro fa vedere un po che
faccino creare guardati tutti gli occhi
di chi potevano capitare proprio quello
incappucciato il peggiore ma è stata
fortunata perché con la pelle si
trattata che agli occhiali da panda e i
pori come crateri gli occhi da bocciati
non te li guarda proprio nessuno è loro
amore partire anche una bella base blu
io avevo già fatto la base muore no no
sei bravissima tesoro guarda quasi paura
che mi rubi lavoro portatemi della
struccante veloce per favore senti per
gli occhi io farei un bel haj fox un
bell'occhio di volpe come va di moda
adesso però rimaniamo sempre sulla tua
palette colori che ha così a occhio e
croce tu sei sicuramente una spring
summer 2020 muore però e loseto non va
bene metterlo su dai ai occhiobello
carico le labbra lascerei proprio
scariche scarichi per quasi quasi da
morta guarda su guarda giù dai un bacio
a chi vuoi tu chiudi gli occhi mentre
apri la bocca le piano piano che ti
siano via tutto il trucco